지난 48시간 동안 당신은 'Minimum Edition'을 통해
Trap Score의 압도적인 위력을 직접 체감하셨을 겁니다.
보이지 않는 위협으로부터 자신을 지켜내는
강력한 방패를 가진 느낌이었을 테니까요.
하지만 당신이 점수만 확인하고 있는 이 순간에도,
시장를 움직이는 '세력'들은 이미 진화하고 있습니다.
무료 버전이 단지 '출구'의 위치만 알려준다면,
풀 프로토콜은 전장 전체의 흐름을 통찰하게 해줍니다.
지금 이 순간에도 기관의 정교한 알고리즘은
가짜 신호를 뿌리며 당신의 포모(FOMO)를 자극하고 있습니다.
함정이 발동되는 찰나, 단순한 방패만으로는
절대 충분치 않습니다. 완벽한 시각적 지능 체계가 필요합니다.
Grok, GPT, Gemini, 그리고 CryptoQuant까지
4개의 AI 엔진이 실시간으로 동기화됩니다.
실시간 세력 추적, 심리 필터링,
단 3초 만에 내리는 결론. 이것은 단순한 매매가 아니라,
시장을 장악하기 위한 압도적인 '불공평한 우위'입니다.
새로운 방어자들의 탄생을 기념하여 특별 캠페인을 시작합니다.
오직 선착순 50분께만 드리는 기회입니다.
모든 기능을 50% 할인된 가격으로 해제하십시오.
기관급 보호 시스템을 하루 단 1달러 미만으로.
하지만 50석이 모두 차는 즉시,
링크는 만료되고 가격은 다시 두 배로 뜁니다.
당신의 소중한 자산을 운에 맡기지 마십시오.
지금 즉시 당신의 방어 프로토콜을 업그레이드하십시오.
결제 시 코드 'defend 50'을 입력하십시오.
풀 아카데미의 세계에 오신 것을 환영합니다.
함께 시장의 승자가 됩시다.
지금 바로 혜택을 확인하세요.
승리는 당신의 것입니다.